[Applause]
thank
you sit
down sit
down you girl scouts over there sit down
all right it's Friday so you know what
that means let's welcome tonight's guest
his favorite karaoke song is the Pledge
of Allegiance Fox and Friends we co-host
Pete
hexit G hooker driver's test on a
tractor co-host at the bottom line of
Fox Business
J she's lean keen and can pass for a
teen New York Times bestselling author f
c and the Statue of Liberty looks up to
him New York Times best selling author
comedian and former NWA world
champion
yeah all right before we get to some new
stories let's do
this Greg's
leftovers it's leftovers where I read
the jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll roll Joe Macky up
in a carpet and toss him off a
bridge yeah all right here we go Harvard
president claudian gay resigned after
accusation of plagiarism gay said she
would have caught the errors if she had
a larger pair of
[Laughter]
glasses not surprisingly people said
there was something familiar about a
resignation
[Laughter]
letter actor ship puff has reportedly
converted to
Catholicism after portraying a deacon in
a movie
thank God he didn't play
Hitler Choose
Wisely New York mayor Eric Adams is
calling Texas governor Greg Abbott
diabolical for sending illegal aliens to
his City and when the illegal aliens
finally got there they
[Applause]
agreed massive waves resulting from a
storm in the nor Pacific pounded the
California coast this week streets in La
were washed so clean Governor Nome had
promised to install a Fresh coat of
feces I
know yeah like to see how they do that
people are now buying $500 dog beds for
humans but there is a downside after
just one nap you have a sudden urge to
lick your own
balls
I like how was lick your
[Laughter]
own a tech firm in London is launching a
new show featuring an AI hologram of
Elvis they wanted to make a hologram of
lizo but they ran out of file
Story boom yeah according to experts the
average size of an erect penis is 5.17
in oh my God you poor baby
yeah hey speak for yourself said one
penis
[Applause]
owner USA boxing is instituted a new
transgender policy that allows
biological men to compete against
biological women hey don't laugh I'm a
big fan of female boxers she did my
presence at Macy's
a Florida woman is suing Hershey's
because the Jacko Lantern shaped candies
she bought did not have a face on them
like on the package but imagine how our
kids must have felt on Halloween being
raised by a crazy
person Bill Clinton was named over 50
times in the just released Epstein
documents it would have been more but
those girls sure can run
[Applause]
fast that was
good this week President Biden had to be
reminded by Jill that his favorite food
is ice
cream they also had to be reminded who
Jill
is self-driving cars are now reportedly
exempt from tra traffic tickets in
California I think we found the solution
for protesters blocking the
roads earlier this week a 1.7 magnitude
earthquake shook New York City oh sorry
that was the view switching
seats kids you kids president bid spent
more than onethird of 2023 away from the
White House on vacation he spent the
other two-thirds wrapped in linen inside
a
sarcophagus
sarcophagus according to a recent study
the average American feels just 70%
healthy that seems too high said one
man now to the news a new report says
oops after slandering the troops it's
it's official despite claims of the
Biden White House and their media
lackeys saying that our military is full
of extremists even their latest research
shows that's a lie and like a gay cousin
the report quietly came out right before
Christmas hoping no one would
notice and why because it showed no
extremism in the military of course if
it had shown the opposite it would be on
the front of every news site like one of
Taylor Swift's latest doomed
relationships
the dod commissioned the study which was
put out by The Institute for defense
analysis it quote found no evidence that
the number of violent extremists in the
military is disproportionate to the
number of extremists in the US as a
whole but you must remember back in 2021
defense secretary Lloyd Austin ordered
military leaders to address this
supposed extremist problem after Jan 6
cuz some veterans participated in the
riot and like maggots on a bone boy did
the media eat this up here's MSNBC quote
extremism in the military is a serious
national security threat the GOP needs
to act like it here's CNN the military
has long had an extremism problem I
guess that's called winning
wars what will it do now to finally
solve it an NBR the military confronts
extremism one conversation at a
time so without defining extremism they
say it exists and why cuz it didn't
exist in other words they had to create
something from nothing which is the same
job faced every day by those in charge
of Biden's
campaign but you know what's extreme
lying about people who signed up to
serve their country but are we really
that surprise this is an Administration
that smears first and investigates later
if at all remember the Border agents
supposedly whipping migrants when they
didn't Biden trashed those agents and
the media applauded and and when the
truth came out no apology was given as
the media quickly buried it like a cat
turd in a litter
box and why well they were using
American citizens to create a lie that
our country is Rife with racist hate
therefore voters would need to cling to
Joe and the Dems for safety an absence
of sound policy or ideas that's all they
have but now once again that's shown to
be fullon BS and now the media refuses
to cover it they refuse to defend our
malign troops meanwhile when it comes to
the Epstein court filings the media
bends over backwards to point out that
all the famous names mentioned weren't
accused of any wrongdoing apparently
it's innocent till proven guilty when it
comes to Epstein's Pals but if you're a
border patrol agent a Maga supporter or
in the military you're guilty as
smear if only our troops had better
lawyers meanwhile about Epstein it is
weird that Biden hasn't said a thing
about that perhaps because whatever
happened on that island hits a little
too close to
[Applause]
home Pete you're a US Army veteran or so
you claim um this should piss you off
because when this accusation was put
forth that Prem was universally accepted
in the media and by people who dare not
even question whether there was any data
and universally accepted by generals
yeah so take Mark Millie and Lloyd
Austin okay if this military is so
racist if our ranks are full of
extremists who was in charge over the
last couple decades yeah yeah where you
been all those racist platoon leaders
and staff sergeant that you've been
running around allowed to be skin heads
in clu clux Clan inside the military
what You' been doing about that they
were like they've been doing for decades
cow Towing to their political handlers
who are more interested in social
justice or whatever new ism is involved
and so they're running around talking
about white rage and studying ibra X
kendi about a problem they know doesn't
exist because if you've been in units as
I have been very recently in fact I was
holding a riot shield outside the White
House during the Riots of Summer of 2020
it's a little odd when you're standing
shoulder to shoulder with black guys and
white guys and Hispanic guys and the
White House is behind you and there's
real extremism in front of you and real
racial animosity I you can't imagine
what I heard from these people toward
black soldiers yeah what what the what
the antifa and BLM writers were saying
to the black that was real racism and
what we were doing standing
shoulder-to-shoulder we're saying it
doesn't matter what you're this that's
what all all the leaders of the Pentagon
know this they knew this was a sham so
then they do the study which confirms
what we all know that they're actually
less racists in the military because
you're taught to focus on Merit and your
responsibility and then they bury it and
don't want to talk about it
yeah
amen
amen and while we are obsessed with
so-called extremism in the military
Hamas you know attacks Israel and we're
surprised because we thought the number
one threat was
inside oh absolutely and still on the
internet I'm pissed more than
[Laughter]
usual Times magazine this was January
20th 2021 have you witnessed far-right
extremism inside the military and it's a
little survey you can fill out because
those don't know anybody in actual
service of the country so there's that
that's true
um this is all at a time when our
fighting force is the smallest it's been
since before World War II when
recruiting is a huge problem when trust
and in the military has plummeted to a
record low so we need a volunteer army
of just regular old Americans who will
gently punish these lying hysterics or
these hysterical liars I'm signing up
like uh I got this great oyster shucker
for Christmas yeah that'll do a number
on somebody's tires yeah oh oh I thought
I was like
whoa whoa I'm glad she said tire tire
cuz I was yeah
who little flaming flaming feces saxs of
it Bine canine
poran whatever you need no I'm right
here
Pat this must be especially uh difficult
for you cuz you're married to a veteran
and he is a racist
no I'm joking I'm he's not a racist that
explains the wedding invite not showing
up I'm kidding he's not a racist but
this is he's also like so nice to you I
know he's not even here so that's a
really up thing to it's a joke he
literally did her hair yeah for a year
while we made fun of him Cammy Salon
yeah I did make up a song yeah and he
did serve this country yes and thank
you and he was in the same unit as Pete
was actually not at the same time but I
think it's so awful that these people
who literally signed their lives for
this country right and the same people
who are like yeah I know that we've sent
you away to fight in these wars that
we've been busted lying about like a lot
and you know people have died uh but we
don't want to talk about that instead
we're going to talk about how you guys
are probably a bunch of violent racists
it's truly disgusting and it's so absurd
that it has to be some kind of
distraction to avoid them from so many
so many years decades actually of
accountability that military leadership
not the people who are actually fighting
not it's they say it's the suits not the
boots right we're actually there but
Decades of accountability they're like
nope let's talk about something that
we're just going to make up instead yeah
you know Tyrus it still bugs me like we
were covering this epscene stuff and
every time none of these people have
been charg none of these people we have
to say that legally but when this story
ran everybody in the media said oh you
know extremism is in the military that's
just a that's just a given well Greg and
I'm sorry Pete there is extremism in and
around the military yes they're the ones
reporting on yeah it's the the
extremists who are attacking the
military yeah cuz just the idea of young
men who usually come from lower
socioeconomical places join the military
to see the world and work together and
let's say me and Pete were in a foxhole
together and he got hit right and he
needed someone he needed a pint of blood
and someone to carry him out and it was
just me old Blacky black
Tyrant and I said to Pete all right man
I'm gonna have to do the I'll wait till
someone is I wait for O'Reilly wait for
O'Reilly no seriously I'll carry you out
no no no no no no no I'll wait I'll wait
I'll wait it doesn't happen no one's
ever with enemy Fire coming down looking
around going how long is the black guy
going to be in the Foxhole just it's
made up but it's by the extremist and to
your point Greg you said they they never
investigate cuz it's not about you just
this is how they work they just say and
they don't have it because they feel
military is racist because these guys
get up at 400 a.m. and they train yes
and they do it for God and Country and
their family and they're willing to
bleed to keep us on couches
talking and all of that takes hard work
hard work integrity and accountability
and that is Extreme to the progressives
there you go all
right well set hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else